c'est un tableau digne d'un naturaliste
le bruitissement léger des feuillages
des bouquets de nénuphar posés sur un
plan d'eau entouré d'une forêt de bambou
rouge et au milieu de ce tableau un
jeune violon céniste le décor est
planté Daniel chic est un réalisateur
foisonnant et inventif pour le décor de
son film il a jeté son dévolu sur les
Jard de chumon sur Loire comme un cri du
cœur pour célébrer l'art et la nature à
sa manière vous aimez vous protégé vous
jouissez des choses ça peut ne pas durer
vous aimez un arbre faut pas l'abattre
vous aimez les singes vous êtes pas
obligé de les tuer vous aimez manger
vous pouvez manger bien et puis on
raconte aussi dans le film l'histoire de
l'art la nature et l'art Edgar Mor 21
ans est un petit prodige de violenceè
prix du jeune soliste au concours
ostropovic 2 pr au concours
international
tovski je pense que la nature comme la
vie en
général c'est on peut y voir toutes les
émotions et la musique imite sera bien
ça c'està-dire que avec la musique on va
essayer justement de reproduire
certaines émotions qu'on pourrait
retrouver dans la nature et donc je
pense que le choix de faire justement
des des œuvres comme ça avec montrer
différentes facettes un peu de ce que
peut être l'émotion et ben c'est une
belle façon de rendre mat à la nature
avec leur création originale audacieuse
les artistes ont fait de ces jardins un
lieu où l'art et la nature dialogu en
permanence la présence de Yolande Morau
de ce violencéliste extraordinaire et
d'autres artistes qui sont intervenus
depuis 3 jours sont le signe que c'est
un lieu où la relation avec le monde
l'environnement la nature sont tout à
fait harmonieux clim art le documentaire
de Daniel chic sera diffusé sur France 5
fin novembre d'accord